[Music]
it always warms my heart every single
time
they say
this makes me feel just like when i was
at my grandmother's house
ultimately for me it's about expressing
love to people in the way of baking it's
not a big thing it's not overly
complicated it's really just about like
where's your heart
i'm devonna banks i reside in pasadena
california and i'm the proud owner of
butter bakery
i've owned a business before but it has
nothing to do with baking at all the
challenge was that you have to have a
job obviously so you can take care of
your children and have a roof over your
head and blah blah blah but i needed
something for me like i needed to be
full i baked a lot but i didn't really
think of it as a business per se not at
first i just thought i love this so much
and all i want to do is bake every
single day
it wasn't a thing of
oh i'm just gonna open a bakery business
i didn't think about that at all i
didn't feel like that was where i was
drawn to or that this is the business
that i should go into or any of those
things it was more about oh this is
something i think is fun this is
something that i love to do anyway and
it wasn't until i saw
that people really liked the things that
i make from a perspective of
oh i'll pay for it
butter bakery is the taste of warm
chocolate chip cookies it's delectable
butter pound cakes it's warm even peach
cobbler and ice cream it's all the
things that you have in the comfort of
being at your grandma's house that's who
we are that's what we do as much as i
would i l i would love i would love very
much to have a brick and mortar but it's
a little challenging trying to find an
actual space for the business very much
online presence currently we're not
operating in one set place it's either
commercial kitchens i've even used
schools i've used church kitchens my own
kitchen it's just i'm all over the place
right now just getting it done making
things work so the challenge in that is
having to take everything you have
everywhere you go so you have
just lots of stuff to lug every single
day
i i just kind of feel like people don't
really respect your business if they
don't see it in an actual building
people tend to not take you seriously
so they think
she's just this is a hobby and it's
really not
baking is something that i love and i
love every day that i wake up and before
the sun gets up regardless of what
things come my way
none of that really matters to me
because i love what i do and i'm super
passionate about it every single day no
matter what that looks like and even if
it seems to other people like it's a
challenge or that it's frustrating or
what have you
nothing in me nothing outside of me
makes me feel like
oh i don't want to do this anymore
because every day this is all i want to
do i just want to get up and i want to
bake and i want to do what i do and
that's it so there is no real challenge
if you will not for me not to me
so right now i i'm waiting
waiting for a building i've already like
submitted a letter of intent and so
hopefully they'll come back to me before
the new year and i don't know if i
should say that because of the timing
but
yeah
so it's been about a month since we
interviewed last
and from that point till now
the property management company reached
out and offered me the building
so i'm super excited that butter bakery
will now have its own space
from a personal level um
all of this is surreal it doesn't even
seem
like a reality for butter bakery though
it feels like it's supposed to be
when i started butter bakery i had a
five pound bag of sugar
a five pound bag of flour i had a pack
of butter and i thought this five pound
bag of sugar right here
will eventually become
5 000 pounds
if there's something that you love
it's something that's way on the inside
it doesn't matter what people think it
doesn't matter what people say it
doesn't matter what people make you feel
like even in that moment if you love it
enough
do it
don't allow your
drive and your passion and your love for
something to go to the grave with you
don't go there with regret leave it for
everybody else that's why you have it
all of these things are deposited in us
for the benefit of everybody around us
i would like to be able to like touch
people i would like to be able to like
touch them in their heart with just the
little things that i do and to me they
seem small because this is what i do
every day but sometimes that's all that
matters sometimes that's all that really
is needed like sometimes people just
need cookies cause cookies are good
inevitably i know that working as hard
as i do that i will get the things that
i want from this so that's why i keep
doing it i'm devonna banks the proud
owner of butter bakery where things are
always homemade from scratch
oh yes
you